hey Luca Nate here with the outdoor boys
YouTube channel if you guys remember
correctly last week we tried to polish a
ball of aluminum foil and we had mixed
results it went okay well we're trying
it again and this time we nailed it
[Music]
welcome to another episode of outdoor
boys and if you guys have no idea what
I'm talking about check out this video
from last week there's this trend in
Japan of people taking aluminum foil and
compressing it and polishing it until
you get these super shiny polished balls
of aluminum foil it's kind of a neat
little challenge so last week I give it
a go with me and my boys and this was
our result this is three entire rolls a
hundred and twenty square feet of
aluminum foil now you can see we got it
really round really smooth super dense
but there's still a lot of wrinkles and
textures and there's little bits where
the ball is starting to unravel so we're
gonna see if we can't do even better
additionally a lot of you guys left
great comments trying to guess the
weight of this ball so let me show you
how much it actually weighs two hundred
and sixty grams or nine point five
ounces it's not super heavy but for
aluminum foil it feels pretty chunky a
lot of people also wanted to know what
would happen if I put a polished
aluminum ball in a microwave oven or if
I cut it into what it would look like
inside so I'm gonna do just that and
post the videos here in the near future
so please click subscribe so you can
check out those videos that are coming
out I'm also gonna put a link in the
description to those videos and put a
link up here to those videos when I
posted this original video a lot of you
guys love great comments suggesting that
I should have sanded the ball to get it
more polished unfortunately this wasn't
possible because of the way I built the
ball every time I try to sand it it
would just eat a hole in the outer layer
of aluminum foil and make it more rough
and flappy let me show you what I'm
talking about instead of making it
smoother it just started flaking off big
pieces of aluminum and then making it
actually rough if it actually caused all
these little flappy parts to pop up and
I think that's because of the way I made
my first ball so I'm gonna give this
another go and see what happens and
instead of taking a small ball and
adding one layer on top of the other
very smoothly I'm going to take a big
ball and crinkle it up and see what
happens
this thing is just kind of like falling
apart the more I hit it pretty well
compressed it in a ball form but it just
keeps wanting to come apart on me it's
just I can't polish this I mean it's so
loose it'll just come off look at this
thing it's an absolute disaster the more
I hit it the more it just tries to come
apart okay I might have lost my cool
with that last experiment there so I
instead I'm gonna calm down and I'm
gonna focus here and instead of just
whacking this with the four pound hammer
and going nuts I'm gonna try to be a
little more gentle first I'm gonna just
compress it you wanna help me hit right
there right there yeah all right nice
and round so far we're just gonna keep
shrinking it and compacting it hey use
the other end but if you want to use the
flat end so I've got a flappy bit right
here and I'm gonna try something a
little crazy I'm gonna bend the flapping
bit back like that and see if that helps
and then beat that in there well it's
going a lot better than it did last time
but I'm still having the same problem I
had last time
big splits whenever I try to really
dramatically change the shape of this it
just splits on me once it gets this
condensed it's really kind of brittle
and I can't be monkeying around with the
general shape of it much I can knock
little ridges off but I can't really
mole
it much Nathan what did you do with my
flattening hammer where is it well I've
got two problems folks first my son
Nathan has lost my flattening hammer
somewhere in these leaves behind me
somewhere here I think I don't know
and two the more I try to fix these
cracks the more they just pop up it's
like I'm making them worse I need to
start over again and I need to be
gentler and I need to be more careful
unfortunately I'm out of aluminum foil
so I need to make a run to the store
alright guys it's another day and I've
got another roll of tin foil we're gonna
do it we will succeed trampoline
[Music]
so this is what I'm gonna do differently
instead of squishing it and then trying
to form it into a ball which causes
cracking I'm going to form it into a
ball then slowly compress it maintaining
that ball shape the entire time don't
hit it with the hammer we're not we're
not really hitting it with a hammer much
this time okay I haven't been beating
this with a hammer much I've just been
rolling it and compressing it with my
hands it's pretty hard it's pretty round
but for comparison's sake let me show
you this so this was the last ball I did
which was also one entire roll of
aluminum foil but this one I beat on it
quite a bit now to put that in
comparison this little ball right here
is three entire rolls of aluminum foil
there's a lot of pits and grooves in it
now to take an enormous amount of
sanding and I have to remove a lot of
material to get rid of that if I
compress it more I should get a smoother
surface and it shouldn't be as much
sanding I think if I can press it just a
little bit more we might be ready for
polishing all right so you can see I've
made a lot of progress compressing this
thing compare it to the last attempt
idea at this point I might try sanding
it and see what happens I'm gonna do a
little experiment I'm gonna pull out my
belt sander
well it's definitely sanding it
unfortunately who went flying and put a
you told Edmond
so maybe not the best technique well I'm
gonna try sanding this thing with my
orbital sander it's a little bit gentler
than the belt sander so might go a
little bit better we'll see
better get my respirator on reading
aluminum isn't good for you what happens
as you take the mask off it will be very
painful for you
[Music]
so this is uh what it looks like so far
and hey hey you've not done sanding it
but look at the difference oh I like it
look at that guys that looks pretty darn
cool well unfortunately though I'm
losing all my sunlight and it's time to
get the kids down to bed and eat some
dinner so I have got to put this up for
the day welcome back everybody
and it's another beautiful day and we're
going to keep standing on this aluminum
ball now yesterday I was using the
orbital sander to do it and that worked
okay but you know what I'm gonna give
hand-sanding a try so I'm gonna up the
game here - what is this a 180 grit you
know what I actually like this better
than the herbal Center I think it's
actually faster more work but it's
faster all right now we're gonna try
some 400 grit it's going pretty fast
actually this isn't taking too much time
because the aluminum so soft well that's
what it looks like after the 1500 grit
now let's hit it with a 3,000 grit well
that's what it looks like after the 3000
grit got some green buffing compound and
I've got an electrical drill with the
buffing attachment on it
[Music]
there we go people well you can see I
got this new one a lot more shiny than
the old one it's quite impressive
Wow oh that is impressive
[Music]
pick it up you can hold it hands are
dirty so I don't want to smudge it
pretty true as well
rolls really well they're trying to a
policy a little bit with wet wipes get
my dirty fingerprints off of it yeah wow
that's a lot Wow look at that baguette
that is crazy shiny look at my
reflection hi there and see me my DSLR
here
wow that's pretty impressive isn't it
it's impressive yeah that is crazy
thanks for watching we hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you'd like to see
more great videos from the outdoor boys
YouTube channel don't forget to click
Subscribe we put out new videos every
week and don't forget to hit that Bell
button so you'll get notified when we
put out another great video